weiter an diesem Freitagnachmittag 2
dezember in den Tagesordnungspunkt 36
das ist das sogenannte
kita-qualitätsgesetz und Regelungen zu
sprachkitas das ist ein zweites Gesetz
zur Weiterentwicklung der Qualität und
zur Teilhabe in der Kindertagesbetreuung
kurz in die kitaqualitätsgesetz das
ganze hier in der zweiten und dritten
Lesung eingesetzt Entwurf der
Bundesregierung die zuständige
Ministerin Lisa Paus hier auch schon im
Raum wir sehen sie auch bereits mit
ihrem Manuskript auf der Regierungsbank
und sie wird jetzt gleich das Wort
erteilt bekommen durch die
bundestagsvizepräsidenten Lisa Pause
die Bundesfamilienministerin
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Gäste liebe Eltern Liebe Erzieherinnen
Kitas sind ein wahrer Job und
zukunftsmotor auf dem Arbeitsmarkt im
Jahr 21 waren mehr als 860.000 Menschen
in Kitas und in der Kindertagespflege
tätig mehr Menschen als in der deutschen
Automobilindustrie
die Zahl der Erzieherinnen hat sich in
den letzten 15 Jahren verdoppelt allein
der teilarbeitsmarkt so frühkindlichen
Bildung ist dreimal so stark gewachsen
wie der gesamte deutsche Arbeitsmarkt
und in der selben Zeit stieg die Zahl
der Kinder die bis zu ihrer Einschulung
in Kitas betreut werden um mehr als 30
Prozent auf 3,4 Millionen es gab also
noch nie so viele Beschäftigte und noch
nie so viele Kitaplätze wie heute wir
haben wirklich viel erreicht
und deshalb investieren wir jetzt in die
Qualität denn jenseits ihrer Familien
lernen kleine Kinder an keinem anderen
Ort so viel wie am Bildungsort Kita am
Bildungsort Kita wird das Fundament
gelegt für frühkindliche Bildung für die
Sprachentwicklung für die gesunde
Entwicklung insgesamt für
Chancengerechtigkeit für jedes Kind also
in Kitas entscheidet sich und im übrigen
auch ob sich Eltern Alleinerziehende vor
allem Frauen darauf verlassen können
dass sie Job und Familie vereinbaren
können wie wichtig das ist das
bestätigen uns auch immer mehr
Unternehmen und darum investieren wir in
die Qualität für die Bildungsorte Kita
und Kindertagespflege und allen muss das
viel Wert sein und Länder und Kommunen
und darum stellt der Wunsch den Ländern
den nächsten zwei Jahren rund vier
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung damit sie
überwiegend in sieben zentrale Bereiche
der frühkindlichen Bildung investieren
und darum bereiten wir auch jetzt schon
den nächsten Schritt vor bundesweite
Standards durch das
qualitätsentwicklungsgesetz denn genau
da wollen wir hin das Kita-Kinder
bundesweit die gleiche hohe Qualität
erleben egal ob Sie eine Kita in
Cuxhaven am Tegernsee in Anklam oder im
Erzgebirge besuchen
das gehört dazu wenn wir über
gleichwertige Lebensverhältnisse in
Deutschland sprechen meine Damen und
Herren
fest steht ebenso gute frühkindliche
Bildung braucht qualifizierte Fachkräfte
und darum entwickeln wir auch gemeinsam
mit den Ländern Kommunen und weiteren
Akteuren neben der Verankerung im
kitaqualitätsgesetz für die Gewinnung
von Fachkräften eine Gesamtstrategie für
die Fachkräfte Sicherung in der in den
erziehungsberufen
denn wir brauchen den Schulterschluss
mit allen beteiligten Akteuren wir
müssen alle Möglichkeiten in den Blick
nehmen gutes Personal zu bekommen
durchaus und Weiterbildung durch gute
Arbeitsbedingungen durch Integration von
Zugewanderten ich zähle auf Ihre
Unterstützung herzlichen Dank
soweit die kompakte Einführung durch die
Bundesministerin durch Lisa Pauls Kita
qualitätsgesetz und Sprach- nächste
Redner Rente Routine für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
es hat werden sagen sie ich Frage
wirklich weil der Evaluationsbericht zum
sogenannten gute Kita-Gesetz eins zwar
Reformbedarf bescheinigt haben mag das
aber dieses Ziel mit dem
kita-qualitätsgesetz über das wir heute
beraten auch tatsächlich erreicht wird
bezweifle ich nicht nur sondern bin fest
davon überzeugt dass es so nicht
funktionieren wird liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen weil ist der Ampel nämlich
genau nicht darum geht was sie außen
drauf geschrieben haben nämlich nicht um
Qualität weil dieser Gesetzentwurf eine
Mogelpackung ist
Etikettenschwindel ist und warum das so
ist werde ich Ihnen erläutern sie legen
einen Gesetzentwurf vor in dem es vor
allem um eines geht ausschließlich um
Beitrags Entlastung schreiben aber
Qualität drauf und das ist wirklich
fatal liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
dass es unehrlich es ist ungerecht es
sorgt nicht für mehr Qualität und es
sorgt auch nicht für mehr
Gleichwertigkeit von Lebensverhältnissen
die unsere Verfassung auch vorgibt und
ich möchte mich das schon mal auch an
die Familien richten an die
Erzieherinnen und Erzieher da draußen
weil ich nicht glaube dass sie es
wirklich hinbekommen allen glaubhaft zu
machen dass die Bundesmittel die sie
hier in die Hand nehmen für eine
Finanzierung für angebliche Qualität die
dann am Ende tatsächlich nur hin zur
beitragsentlastungen geht auch teilweise
in Bundesländern zur vorliegenden
Beitragsfreiheit von Eltern und das auch
noch unabhängig vom Einkommen und das
kann doch nicht wirklich ernst sein
Liebe
laut ihres Gesetzentwurfs ist es nämlich
so dass die Bundesländer in denen
bislang noch keine Mittel aus dem gute
Kita-Gesetz für die Senkung von
Elternbeiträgen eingesetzt wurde wie
beispielsweise in Baden-Württemberg auch
künftig von der von dieser Option
ausgeschlossen werden auch dann wenn sie
schon ein top-qualitätsniveau haben und
wo gibt es jetzt schon ein Top
Qualitätsniveau beispielsweise in Bayern
und ich weiß dass sie das wieder
triggern wird an dieser Stelle im
Gegensatz dazu dürfen aber Länder die
wie zum Beispiel Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
den schlechtesten Personalschlüssel von
allen Bundesländern aufweisen man
überlegen wir da regiert dürfen auch
weiterhin die Bundesmittel für
Beitragsentlastung ausgeben und das ist
nicht richtig liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich sag nur finde den Fehler
und dann schauen Sie sich mal den
Ländermonitor an wenn sie mal Blick in
den Ländermonitor werfen das stets auch
zum Nachlesen auch für die SPD auch für
die Grünen wer es wieder ganz vorne
Bayern an dieser Stelle und wen wundert
Schlusslicht natürlich Bremen und Berlin
also auch nicht verwundernswert wäre in
diesen Ländern regiert und wenn wir dann
noch sehen wie wertvolle
Qualitätsmaßnahmen wie die sprachkitas
die Fachkräfte Offensive Erzieherinnen
und Erzieher oder auch unser
Bundesprogramm pro Kindertagespflege
ohne Not von ihnen platt gemacht werden
spätestens dann kauft dieser gesamten
Regierung niemand mehr ab dass ihnen
frühkindliche Bildung am Herzen liegt
frühkindliche Bildung und das können sie
durch zugeben ist Ihnen doch lästig sie
nehmen doch offen in Kauf dass sich die
Qualität verschlechtert und ihnen ist
völlig egal ob diese Bundesmittel in die
Qualität gehen oder in die Beiträge
gehen aber sich dann hinstellen als
halsbringer für Qualität das ist
wirklich in Farm
ich darf
ich darf einen großen Mann dieses Hauses
zitieren Matthias Seestein pauli hat als
ihr eigener Koalitionspartner schon beim
gute Kita-Gesetz eins in der zweiten und
dritten Lesung gesagt genau wegen der
Regelungen zur Beitrags Entlastung hat
er dieses Gesetz als verpasste
chancengesetz bezeichnet und ich finde
woher sie entstand pauli Recht hat hatte
einfach Recht an dieser Stelle und
deswegen kann ich heute noch sagen ich
werde das noch erweitern Herr Seestadt
pauli nicht nur das verpasste
chancengesetz sondern es ist eine Rolle
rückwärts gesetzt was sie hier vorlegen
wir als Union lehnen eine Finanzierung
von Beitrags Entlastungen bis hin zur
völligen Beitragsfreiheit aus
Bundesmitteln ab die für ein
kitaqualitätsgesetz gedacht sind noch
dazu wenn es unabhängig vom Einkommen
der Eltern passieren soll für uns kommt
Qualität
vorbeitragsentlastung deswegen kann ich
sie nur auffordern unserem Antrag
zuzustimmen wenn ihnen die Kinder
wirklich am Herzen liegen wenn das seit
einem Jahr nicht nur Lippenbekenntnisse
sehen dann wird es sehr traurig wenn Sie
hier nicht mitmachen ganz herzlichen
Dank
Dorothee Bär die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Unionsfraktion
Mitglieder CSU hier noch einmal mit dem
Hinweis darauf dass es in der
aktientuierung Unterschiede gibt und
dass die Union darauf wird legt das in
ihrem Entschließungsantrag dass die
Bundesmittel vor allen Dingen für den
Kita qualitätsgesetz ausschließlich für
die höhere Qualität der Betreuung
einzusetzen sind Geräte entgegnet jetzt
für die koalitionsfraktion SPD-Fraktion
gelesen haben
und ich
und ich weiß auch und ich weiß auch
nicht ob sie ihn wirklich mit dem mit
der alten Gesetzeslage verglichen haben
denn und das sage ich als Sozialdemokrat
der Beitragsfreiheit nach wie vor für
ein richtiges instrumental hält denn ich
sage wir haben genau das Gegenteil von
dem getan was sie gerade beschrieben
haben genau das Gegenteil im Gegensatz
im Gegensatz zum
Gesetz was damals von der cdu/cs und der
SPD auf den Weg gebracht worden ist
schränken wir die Möglichkeit der
Beitragsfreiheit mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf ein wir fahren es zurück
es wir geben mehr in die Qualität mehr
in die qualitätspunkte und weniger und
weniger für die Beitragsentlastung das
ist aktuell die Veränderung vom Gesetz
dass wir beide gemeinsamer beschlossen
haben zum ampelgesetz das müssen sie
einfach anerkennen das sind Fakten vor
der das sind faktenverwert
und sie haben deshalb von verpasste
Chancen ich glaube mich auch camion
erinnern als der Kollege sehr schnell
pauli das gesagt hat ich finde sie haben
jetzt ihre Chance vertan hier
tatsächlich zum aktuellen vorliegenden
Gesetzentwurf was zu sagen
und das wundert mich wirklich
tatsächlich weil ich die Debatten und
die Verhandlungen mit der Union damals
geführt habe und ich hätte jetzt
eigentlich erwartet dass sie gesagt
haben denn sie es war die Union die
damals uns dafür kritisiert hat dass wir
die Beitragsfreiheit reingebracht haben
und ich hätte mich gefreut wenn sie
jetzt zumindest anerkannt haben dass die
Ampelkoalition den Weg verlassen hat der
damals gemacht worden ist das hätten sie
ruhig mal tun können denn wir machen
jetzt mehr in Beitrags wir machen jetzt
weniger einen Beitrag Stabilität und
mehr in Qualität im Gegenwehr werden
sogar und das ist sage ich mal nach wie
vor und Sie Fragen an nach der
Verbesserung gefragt der aktuellen
Situation wir als Bund haben in der
Vergangenheit über 9 Milliarden Euro in
die Hand genommen zur Verbesserung der
Qualität in Kindertagesstätten und wir
werden jetzt zukünftig noch mal wieder
zwei Milliarden und 1,9 Milliarden für
den nächsten Jahren
1,89 Milliarden für die nächsten für die
nächsten Jahre noch mal in die Hand
nehmen wir werden also zusätzliches Geld
für Aufgaben der Länder bereitstellen
und das ist eine Verbesserung der
Situation vor Ort
wir gehen den Weg weiter den die jungen
Ministerkonferenz 2014 damals auf
Initiative von Manuela Schwesig auch
gemeinsam im Dialog mit
Wirtschaft mit Fachverbänden gegangen
ist wir gehen diesen Weg konsequent
weiter wir sagen es ist aufgrund der
Tatsache dass wir uns als Bund auch
dafür zuständig fühlen gleiche
Lebensverhältnisse bundesweit auszubauen
dass wir auch sagen wir nehmen dieses
Geld in die Hand und das will ich noch
mal sagen gerade angesichts der
aktuellen Zeiten muss man auch mal
anerkennen dass es leider keine
Selbstverständlichkeit immer in allen
Debatten ist nein aber für uns ist es
eine Selbstverständlichkeit dass wir
diese Mittel für Kindertagesstätten zur
Verfügung stellen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und mit diesem wirklich großem Gesetz
setzen wir das fort was wir in der
Vergangenheit begonnen haben und was wir
auch noch in der nächsten Zeit mit dem
startschancenprogramm mit der weiteren
Reform bei Bafög mit der
Kindergrundsicherung wir werden für
bessere Chancen für Kinder sorgen das
macht die Ampel das macht die
forschungskoalition danke schön
das für die
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion der gleichzeitig
von Hause aus von Beruf Erzieherin
Erzieher ist nächste Rednerin ist für
die afd-fraktion
Nicole höchst sie stellvertretendes
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Bildung
Forschung und Technik Folgen Abschätzung
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
ich möchte beleuchten was wieder keiner
sieht sie beweisen mit diesem
wohlklingenden Kita qualitätsgesetz eine
realitätsferne und einen mangelnden
Weitblick die zusammen größer nicht sein
könnten Geld an sich ist keine
Verbesserung der Situation Herr Ricks in
der letzten Legislatur war das Gute
Kita-Gesetz von Frau aus dem damals SPD
geführten Ministerium das selbst nach
Einschätzung der GEW bereits an der
Realität gescheitert ist keine
Verbesserung trotz häufigen Hessens des
Regenbogens wollte das Gesetz nicht die
angepriesenen Effekte erzielen im
Gegenteil die Attraktivität
pädagogischer Arbeit in Kitas sank ins
Bodenlose die Überforderung der
Beschäftigten durch unbesetzte Stellen
Bürokratiemonster und organisatorische
Klimmzüge
stiegen geeignetes Personal Fehlanzeige
Vertretung von hauszeiten unmöglich es
folgten Reduzierungen der Angebote und
Einschränkungen bei den Öffnungszeiten
gute Kita geht anders meine Damen und
Herren
das Ziel des neuen wohlklingenden
Gesetzes nämlich qualitativ hochwertige
Betreuung zu gewährleisten für Familien
die dieses Angebot nutzen wollen oder
nutzen müssen ist ein wichtiger Schritt
allerdings boykottieren sie dieses Ziel
selbst weil sie sich nicht mit den
Konsequenzen ihrer Politik der letzten
Jahrzehnt auseinandersetzen wollen sie
wollen nicht hören wenn ihnen Fachleute
die Folgen ihrer Politik sichtbar machen
der Präsident des Deutschen
Lehrerverbandes Heinz Peter Meininger
bespricht den IQB
bildungsabwärtstrend in Deutschland
pessimistisch er spricht schonungslos an
was Sie meine Damen und Herren hier im
Parlament von meiner Fraktion seit
Jahren gesagt bekommen aber in ihrer
ideologischen Verblendung nicht hören
wollen die Lernleistungen von Kindern
mit und ohne
migrationshintergrundklassen sichtbar
auseinander ihre resettlement in
replacement Politik sowie andauernde
Massenzuwanderung nach Deutschland
vergrößern dieses Problem
tätig pädagogischer Unsinn gescheiterte
integrations- und inklusionspolitik plus
ungebremste Zuwanderung besiegeln den
Absturz Deutschlands als bildungsnation
bereits in der Kita resettlement
bedeutet Umsiedlung replacement bedeutet
Ersetzung oder ersatzmigration eine
Politik die jede Fraktion hier im
Bundestag mitträgt außer der
afd-fraktion meine Damen und Herren
bereits heute werden vielerorts fast
heftig und eben schon überhälftig nicht
deutsch muttersprachliche Kinder in
Kitas betreut diese babylonischen
Zustände kommen unweigerlich im
deutschen Schulsystem an dass sie von
der ampelregierung die gute etablierten
sprach geht das nicht fortführen wollen
passt zur mangelnden Bereitschaft Frau
Ministerin stark watzingers das
Bekenntnis zu deutsch als
Unterrichtssprache unseres Landes
abzulegen dabei ist Deutsch in
Deutschland der Schlüssel zur
Integration diese Weigerung ist ein
deutliches Signal und auch entlarven für
die Weichenstellung dieser und
vergangener Bundesregierung die
hauptleitragenden sind alle Kinder wie
sehen die Ampel Lösungen aus sie kleben
zukünftig das Etikett Deutsch auf alles
Fremde erreichen damit das zukünftig die
Zuwanderung in
bildungsvergleichstestungen
bildungsberichten und Bildungs-
religionsanarchie der Kultur der jeweils
vor Ort stärksten Sprechergruppe
gewährleisten Sie dass Deutsch
muttersprachliche Kinder zukünftig in
Deutschland die Mehrheit und nicht die
Minderheit sind ohne diesen wichtigen
Schritt wird der deutsche Turm zu Babel
fallen egal wie wohl klingt ihre
kita-gesetze sein mögen und zum Schluss
wenn es wenn sie so weitermachen alle
miteinander folgt die deutsche
bildungsnation dem Trend der deutschen
Fußballnation wir fliegen raus aus dem
weltweiten Wettbewerb vielen Dank
[Applaus]
so weiter Redebeitrag von Nicole höchst
afd-fraktion die bildungspolitische
Sprecherin wir sind weiter in der
Debatte rund ums kita-qualitätsgesetz
das sehr skeptisch von allen
Oppositionsfraktionen übrigens gesehen
wird Matthias sie ist das pauli jetzt
für die FDP-Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Ministerin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
glaube man muss ein bisschen was
einsortieren nach bestimmten reden also
wir haben eine Finanzplanung der alten
unionsgeführten Bundesregierung
übernommen in der weder für die
Fortsetzung des Guten kita-gesetzes noch
für die Fachkräfte offensive oder die
sprach Kitas Gelder eingeplant war
hinzu kommt dass das bisherige gute
Kita-Gesetz ist den Ländern ermöglicht
hat die Bundesgelder ausschließlich in
Pauschale
beitragsabschaffung zu stecken anstatt
in wirkliche Qualitätsmaßnahmen zu
investieren man muss sagen das wurde
leider viel zu häufig genutzt man kann
also festhalten man kann also festhalten
mit dem alten Kita-Gesetz hat es die
letzte Regierung versäumt den Fokus auf
wirkliche Qualitätsverbesserung zu legen
und diese obendrein auch noch finanziell
abzusichern das war die
Ausgangssituation vor der wir gestanden
deshalb haben wir uns als FDP und als
Ampel fest vorgenommen die Qualität der
frühkindlichen Bildung in dieser
Wahlperiode verbindlich zu stärken und
genau das tun wir mit dem
kita-qualitätsgesetz indem wir
wesentliche Verbesserung vornehmen und
die Länder in den nächsten zwei Jahren
mit rund 4 Milliarden Euro unterstützen
und das trotz der aktuell sehr
schwierigen finanziellen
Rahmenbedingungen was bedeutet das aber
konkret und ich möchte das noch mal
ausführen weil ja Vorrednerinnen den
Gesetzentwurf augenscheinlich nicht
gelesen haben es bedeutet dass zukünftig
keine neuen Maßnahmen für pauschale
beitragsabschaffung auf Kosten der
Qualität mehr finanziert werden es
bedeutet dass die Länder nun überwiegend
das heißt mehr als 50 Prozent der Mittel
in die vorrangigen Handlungsfelder
investieren müssen das wiederum eröffnet
den Ländern die Möglichkeit mehr für
Fachkräfte die sprachliche Bildung die
Kindertagespflege oder eine starke
Kita-Leitung zu tun meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren diese Chance sollten
die Länder auch dringend nutzen und vor
allem mit Blick auf die aktuelle
Fachkräfte Situation der
Fachkräftemangel über den wir schon
lange Reden kommt an es ist keine
theoretische Debatte mehr sondern er
wird vor Ort spürbar immer mehr Familien
stehen vor dem Problem der größer
werdenden Betreuungslücke
Kitas in den Notbetrieb gehen müssen
Familien kein Kitaplatz mehr bekommen
oder einige Kitas sogar zeitweise
schließen müssen deshalb müssen Bund und
Länder den Fachkräftemangel als absolute
Priorität behandeln was wir als Bund
auch tun
denn der Fachkräftemangel führt
langfristig dazu dass die Vereinbarkeit
von Familie und Beruf sich drastisch
verschlechtert und die
Chancengerechtigkeit für unsere Kinder
sinkt meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren zusammenfassen kann ich sagen
dass wir heute einen ersten großen
Schritt hin zu deutlich mehr Qualität in
der frühkindlichen Bildung gehen es ist
ein gutes Gesetz den wir als Freie
Demokraten sehr gerne zustimmen vielen
Dank
durchaus erwartbar dass die
Koalitionsfraktionen hier bei diesem
Gesetz zusammenstehen das war jetzt
Matthias Seestern pauli der
familienpolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion Heidi Reicheneck für die
Linke Sprecherin für Kinder und
Jugendpolitik die nächste ampult in
dieser Debatte ums kita-qualitätsgesetz
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen
ich Akita und irgendwie werden das in
Ihrer Gruppe immer mehr Kinder und
irgendwie haben sie immer weniger
Kolleginnen massig Überstunden und
trotzdem eingeschränkte Betreuungszeiten
oder sogar Schließungen dadurch
gestresste schlecht gelaunte Eltern und
gestresste und schlecht gelaunte Kinder
das ist Alltag in Kitas im ganzen Land
und was tut die Bundesregierung jetzt na
sie sagt augen zu und durch in dem
vorliegenden qualitätsgesetz fehlt eine
langfristige Strategie und ganz einfach
Geld das ist kein qualitätsgesetz das
ist ein kürzungsgesetz sie streichen
nicht nur das Geld für die sprachkette
ignorieren auch die massive Inflation
von über 10% und fallen damit hinter das
Niveau das Gute kindergesetzes zurück
als Linke haben wir deshalb einen
schließungsantrag vorgelegt der endlich
für eine Trendwende im vernachlässigen
und kaputt gesparten Kita-Bereich sorgen
würde wir sagen nicht 4 Milliarden für
zwei Jahre sondern 6 Milliarden pro Jahr
müssen zur Verfügung gestellt werden um
Qualität endlich Realität werden zu
lassen dazu brauchen wir 2 Milliarden on
top um den Investitionsstau der Kitas
wenigstens anzugehen und nein das ist
nicht utopisch das Geld ist da dieses
Parlament sie haben gerade erst zehn
Milliarden für eine aktienrente
rausgeworfen da vor 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen zusätzlich für Aufrüstung
obwohl die Verteidigungsministerin dafür
eh schon über 50 Milliarden im Jahr
kriegt wo ist das Sondervermögen für
Kitas frage ich Sie warum finden Sie
Mittel und Wege um die Interessen der
Superreichen durchzusetzen aber nicht
die der Kinder warum lassen wir
Milliarden krisengewinne der
Großkonzerne unangetastet aber für
Kinder ist nichts da
nun ist es so dass uns Geld allein nicht
aus der kitakrise rettet es muss auch
sinnvoll investiert werden also nicht so
wie bei der Bundeswehr die
Bundesregierung hat aber nach wie vor
keinerlei Konzept gegen den
Fachkräftemangel und der hat Gründe die
Fachkräfte werden aktuell nicht nur
bescheiden bezahlt die gehen auch auf
dem Zahnfleisch weil sie immer mehr mit
immer mehr Aufgaben überhäuft werden
Erzieherin hängen ihren Job an den Nagel
weil die nicht mehr können Herr
seelische St Pauli stellen sie eine
Zwischenfrage wenn Sie Fragen haben ne
das muss man erstmal packen das Nerven
Kostüm von Menschen die sich den ganzen
Tag mit Kleinkindern beschäftigen so zu
überlassen
[Applaus]
soll das jetzt der Versuch sein eine
Zwischenfrage zu stellen sie müssen sich
schon melden dafür
okay es wird wohl zugelassen bitte schön
sehr geehrte Kollegin vielen Dank dass
Sie die Zwischenfrage zulassen ich finde
das sehr beeindruckend dass immer darauf
verwiesen wird seitens der Linken hier
im Deutschen Bundestag das ist von einem
mehr und viel schneller geben soll es
gibt ja auch eine gewisse Zuständigkeit
bei der frühkindlichen Bildung bei den
Ländern und da gibt es ein Bundesland
nämlich Thüringen wo sie den
Ministerpräsidenten stellen den
zuständigen Kultusminister und die
Sozialministerin das heißt wirklich alle
die im Bereich der frühkindlichen
Bildung Einfluss nehmen könnten da
werden Tagesmütter mit 2,53 € pro Kind
pro Stunde abgespeist das heißt bei der
maximalen Anzahl von fünf Kindern
sind sie bei 12,65 Euro das heißt knapp
über Mindestlohn bei vier Kindern sogar
darunter in dem Zusammenhang wird mich
mal interessieren sprechen sie
eigentlich mit ihren Kollegen vor Ort
oder sind das alles Sonntagsreden die
sich ausschließlich im Bundestag halten
also vielen Dank für die Zwischenfrage
ich freue mich sehr dass moderne
Ministerpräsident in Thüringen ist das
war ja nicht durch sie ermöglicht sie
hatten da ja andere Prioritäten und
hatten andere Unterstützung aber ja wir
sprechen miteinander gerade morgen
gibt's da ein Gespräch zwischen unseren
Fraktionsvorsitzenden hier im Bundestag
und unseren Ländern da werden wir auch
das Thema ansprechen nämlich das Kita
qualitätsgesetz und genau solche Fragen
und genau zu dem Thema sind wir auch in
Kontakt damit haben sie total rechter
ist viel zu tun aber das ist nicht nur
in Thüringen so sondern in vielen
Ländern und ich glaube wir sind doch
sogar einig dass wir weg müssen vom
Kooperationsverbot und hin zu einem
kooperationsgebot das können wir
zumindestens eine Diskussionen immer
wieder feststellen und ich denke daran
sollten auch in einem Strang ziehen der
Bund ist dafür verantwortlich das wurde
vorhin auch von der SPD gesagt
Vergleiche Lebensverhältnisse zu sorgen
also schieben Sie das nicht immer auf
die Länder ab sondern machen Sie das was
hier möglich ist und das wäre unsere
Entschließungsantrag zuzustimmen
deswegen was müssen wir gegen den
Fachkräftemangel machen natürlich
Ausbildungsplätze schaffen Leute
zurückholen die entnervt aufgegeben
haben und Quereinsteiger in fortbilden
natürlich geht das nicht von jetzt auf
gleich aber wir müssen auch wenigstens
endlich mal anfangen und deswegen
brauchen wir jetzt einen
Beteiligungsprozess bei dem sie endlich
mal auf Leute hören die wissen wovon sie
reden meine Kolleginnen nämlich den Job
machen und die das umsetzen müssen was
sie hier beschließen damit das nächste
Kita-Gesetz nicht wieder so ein naja ist
ja besser als nichts gesetzt wird
zusammengefasst unter der groko gab es
für die Kitas kaum Geld und keinen Plan
mit der Ampel gibt es kaum Geld kein
Plan und totales Chaos in der Umsetzung
und wenn sie zur Abwechslung als
fortschrittskoalition mal
fortschrittliche Politik machen wollen
dann stimmen Sie unserem
Entschließungsantrag zu vielen Dank
hat hier noch mal für die Linksfraktion
als Sprecherin für Kinder und
Jugendpolitik die Vorbehalte von Seiten
der Linken formuliert in der Stahl jetzt
für die Bündnis 90 die Grünen Sprecherin
für Bildung Forschung und
Technikfolgenabschätzung Präsidentin
lieber min
isterin unterhalten die unterrichtet
eine erste Klasse und die erzählte nicht
erst seit Corona aber seitdem verstärkt
kommen viele Kinder in die erste Klasse
die kam eine Schere halten können die
nicht zählen können die selten in einem
Buch geblättert haben sie tut was sie
kann sie möchte jedem Kind die Chance
geben all seine Potenziale zu nutzen und
doch vieles kann man in der Schule nicht
mehr aufholen wenn wir
Chancengerechtigkeit wollen dann müssen
wir viel früher ansetzen deshalb meine
Damen und Herren jetzt ist die Zeit um
in kita-qualität zu investieren und das
machen wir mit dem Kita qualitätsgesetz
deshalb überweisen wir in den nächsten
beiden Jahren knapp vier Milliarden Euro
an die Länder aber legen dabei fest
in Zukunft müssen alle Länder die
überwiegenden Teil der Mittel in
Qualität investieren diese Priorität auf
Qualität ist die entscheidende
Weiterentwicklung im Vergleich zum gute
Kita-Gesetz
ebenso wichtig die Länder können die
Mittel für die Sprachförderung nutzen
die eine so wichtige Säule für die
Entwicklung unserer Kinder ist wir haben
den Gesetzesentwurf in den letzten
Wochen intensiv debattiert und zwei
Änderungen vorgenommen zum einen werden
wir der Bund die sprachkitas letztmalig
für ein halbes Jahr finanzieren so
schaffen wir die Voraussetzungen dass
die Länder die sprach Kitas weiterführen
können denn es liegt in Ihrer
Verantwortung und ich kann es nur noch
einmal wiederholen bitte sprechen Sie
alle mit ihren Kollegen in den Ländern
dass Sie diese Chance auch nutzen
zum anderen
streichen wir die verpflichtende
Staffelung der Elternbeiträge und ich
gebe ehrlich
zu denn ich bin sicher die
einkommensstaffelung ist eigentlich das
genaue zielgenaue Instrument um Familien
mit geringem Einkommen zu entlasten ich
habe aber in den letzten Wochen genau
das auch von vielen Kolleginnen aus den
Ländern gehört jedoch wollen die halten
die eine
bundesgesetzlich einheitliche Ziel einem
Entschuldigung die halten eine
bundesgesetzlich einheitliche Regelungen
nicht für zielführend klar ist ohne
Kompromisse kommen wir nicht weiter und
deshalb gehen wir hier auf die Länder zu
Frau Bär vielleicht ist Ihnen
aufgefallen dass ich bis hierhin heute
nicht einmal das Wort Bayern erwähnt
habe denn ich glaube denn ich glaube
ernsthaft es hilft nicht wenn wir
weitermachen immer die Schuld zwischen
Bund und Ländern hin und her zu schieben
beide Seiten müssen hier ihren Beitrag
leisten zum Wohl der Kinder in diesem
Land mit den vorgenommenen Anpassungen
sind wir einen großen Schritt auf die
Länder zugegangen nun liegt der Ball bei
den Ländern sie können und Sie sollten
am 16 Dezember dem vorliegenden
Gesetzesentwurf im Bundesrat zustimmen
ich danke der Bundesfamilienministerin
für diesen sehr guten Gesetzentwurf mit
dem wir die Weichen für mehr
Chancengerechtigkeit in der
frühkindlichen Bildung stellen das ist
der erste Schritt im nächsten werden wir
zusammen mit den Ländern das
kita-qualitätsgesetz noch
weiterentwickeln hin zu einem
Kita-Gesetz mit bundesweiten
Qualitätsstandards denn jetzt ist die
Zeit um in die kita-qualität zu
investieren herzlichen Dank
Nina Star von den Bündnis Grünen und das
Ministerium geführt von Lina Paus auch
in grüner Hand und da auch noch dabei
der Verweis nach der Entscheidung im
Bundesrat am 16 Dezember liegt noch eine
Menge Arbeit vor dieser Pause nämlich
mit den Ländern über Details zu
verhandeln
freuen sich bundesweit hunderttausende
Kindergartenkinder auf ihren ersten
Schultag und als Grundschullehrerin
hatte ich die Ehre viele kleine ABC
Schützen in der ersten Klasse zu
begrüßen neben der Freude dem Stolz und
der Aufregung war oft auch ein bisschen
Angst zu spüren Angst vor den fremden
Kindern vor Fremden Räumen und auch vor
Erwachsenen vor den Fremden die auf
einmal da waren der Schulstart ist ein
Meilenstein in dem Leben der Kinder und
auf allen Seiten mit großen Erwartungen
verbunden und darum ist es nicht nur für
die schulesche sondern auch für die ganz
persönliche Entwicklung hier besonders
gut vorbereitet zu sein extrem wichtig
bedauerlicherweise steigt aber in den
letzten Jahren neben der Zahl der
zurückstellungen von der Einschulung
auch die Zahl der Entwicklungsdefizite
und wir hörten das auch gerade schon
hinzukommen förderrückstände durch
Corona und auch immer mehr Kinder mit
anderen Muttersprachen und aus ganz
persönlicher Erfahrungen als
Grundschullehrerin kann ich Ihnen sagen
Chancengleichheit sieht hier wirklich
anders aus und meine Damen und Herren
ich spreche für eine ganze Berufsgruppe
wenn ich sage wir Lehrerinnen und Lehrer
können das in der Grundschule nicht mehr
aufholen da ist es zu spät aus diesem
Grund bildet eben die frühkindliche
Bildung ein wichtiges Fundament und auch
ich war einige Stunden in der Woche zur
individuellen Sprachbildung der
kleinsten in den Kindertagesstätten
unterwegs und der Förderbedarf ist enorm
und er wächst weiter und darum war ihr
Vorhaben in den nächsten zwei Jahren
vier Milliarden Euro und die Qualität
der frühkindlichen Bildung zu
investieren Musik in meinen Ohren
jedenfalls so lange bis ich ihren
Gesetzesentwurf gelesen habe denn sie
wollen die Kindertagespflege stärken
lassen dann aber das Programm pro
Kindertagespflege einfach auslaufen sie
sie wollen die Qualität auf Basis der
Evaluationsergebnisse des gute
kita-gesetzes weiterentwickeln und
schließen aber die Beitragsfreiheit eben
nicht aus sie wollen gleichwertige
Lebensbedingungen für das Aufwachsen von
Kindern im Bundesgebiet herstellen
fördern aber zugleich schwarz auf weiß
die bestehenden Unterschiede und
letztlich und das ist der Punkt um den
es immer wieder geht Stufen sie den
Schwerpunkt der sprachlichen Bildung als
vorrangig ein und lassen dann aber
6.600 Einrichtungen mit Sprachförderung
im Regen stehen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist es zu
viel erwartet dass mehr als 50 Prozent
der Mittel eines qualitätsgesetzes auch
für Qualitätsförderung ausgegeben werden
vielleicht ganze 100 Prozent
offensichtlich und gut gemeint ist eben
nicht immer gut gemacht
bedauerlicherweise sind sie sind die
aufgezeigten Widersprüche in ihrem
wollen und in ihrem Handeln zu groß für
unsere Zustimmung in unserem
Entschließungsantrag stellen wir
ausdrücklich da unter welchen
Bedingungen wir Ihrem Vorhaben gern
zugestimmt hätten doch leider waren sie
wenig offen für diese wertvollen
Hinweise wieder von unserer Seite noch
von der Seite der Sachverständigen und
es bleibt zu hoffen dass wir mit ihren
politischen hin und her zum
Bundesprogramm der sprach Kitas nicht
bereits zu viel von unserer wertvollsten
Ressource nämlich den Fachkräften
verloren haben
und dass das Engagement unserer
Erzieherin und Erzieher in den
Einrichtungen vor Ort ihren Einsatz hier
um ein Vielfaches übertrifft vielen Dank
Anne Jansen war das für die
Unionsfraktion sie sitzt im Ausschuss
für Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend
und dann haben wir jetzt den letzten
Redner an diesem debattenpunkt Erik von
Malotki er sitzt ebenfalls in diesem
Ausschuss und spricht für die
SPD-Fraktion Frau Präsident werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in der Qualität
der Kindertagesbetreuung spiegelt sich
die Verantwortung unserer Gesellschaft
für unsere Zukunft wieder diese
Verantwortung wird sichtbar in
qualitativen Anforderungen und
finanziellen Engagement
das ist ein Auszug aus dem von meinem
Kollegen sehr gericks angesprochenen
kommunizé zwischen Bund und Ländern vom
6 November 2014 in dieser wichtigen
beeinkunft waren sich Bund und Länder
einig dass die zusammen in die
frühkindliche Bildung investieren wollen
seit diesem Community ist viel auf den
Weg gebracht worden wir haben 2016 das
Programm sprachkitas geschaffen und wir
haben mit dem gute Kita gesetzt den
Einstieg in die Grundfinanzierung und
die Unterstützung des Bundes in die
Grundfinanzierung der frühkindlichen
Bewegung Bildung begonnen ja mit 500
Millionen im Jahr 2019 angefangen und
haben 2021 das Niveau von 2 Milliarden
Euro erreicht um mit diesem heutigen
Gesetz gehen wir einen weiteren
Zwischenschritt in der Umsetzung dieses
kommunikäses wir stellen für die
nächsten beiden Jahre jeweils ca 2
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung und
stabilisieren damit dieses Niveau und
wir sorgen dafür dass in der Rede nicht
ganz deutlich geworden Frau Bär das ist
ein Großteil dieser Mittel überwiegend
in die brückentliche Bildung
frühkindliche Bildung Qualität fließen
ich will Ihnen mal sagen
was das für mein Bundesland
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern die Erzieherinnen
Erzieher dort bedeutet kleinere Gruppen
im Kindergarten ein
mindestpersonalschlüssel der durch die
Praxis sehr lange schon gefordert wird
und eine eigene fachkräfteoffensive
durch die Mittel die wir heute zur
Verfügung stellen und der Höhepunkt ich
weiß ganz genau dass das so ist Frau Bär
und der Höhepunkt soll aus meiner
sichtbar wird gerade gearbeitet ein
bundesqualitätsentwicklungsgesetz zum
ersten ersten 2025 machen genau zehn
Jahre nach dem Kommunität gehen also
könnte man sagen alles Gute im Bereich
der frühkindlichen Bildung die letzten
Wochen und Monate haben eher eine andere
Sprache gesprochen was wir erlebt haben
ist ein verantwortungs Pingpong zum
Thema sprachkitas der Bund sagt die
Länder sind für das Thema zuständig die
Länder sagen wir haben nicht die
finanziellen Mittel dafür der Bund
verweist auf das höhere Steueraufkommen
der Länder die Länder sagen sie haben in
der coronazeit viel investiert und haben
eine ältere Schuldenbremse und ich ewig
so weitermachen
worum geht es in dieser Debatte
eigentlich nicht
um unsere Kinder und die Zukunft unserer
Gesellschaft
und deswegen ist meine Forderung meine
bitte lassen Sie uns weg vom
verantwortungs-pingpong hin zu einer
Verantwortungsgemeinschaft zwischen Bund
und Ländern kommen
und
wir gehen heute mit diesem Gesetzentwurf
ein wichtig und mit diesem Gesetz
Beschluss einen wichtigen Weg wir
stellen für sechs Monate verlängern wir
das Programm sprachkitas und die
Bestätigung der sprachkita ist aus
meiner Sicht der Lackmustest für diese
Verantwortungsgemeinschaft ich höre aus
vielen Bundesländern sehr gute
Nachrichten aus NRW aus Niedersachsen
aus Mecklenburg-Vorpommern sagen mir die
Erzieherinnen jetzt hier es ist eine
gute Lösung wir haben eine Sicherheit
die Länder übernehmen das Programm es
gibt einige wenige Länder in das nicht
so ist eins davon ist Bayern was ich
dort höre ist Angst Unsicherheit wir
wissen nicht wie es weitergeht deswegen
ist mein Appell an alle
verantwortungsträgerinnen und
Verantwortungsträger aus Bayern bitte
erhalten Sie die Sprache Kitas erhalten
Sie die Strukturen sichern Sie das
Wissen der Fachkräfte in den
sprachgitters
was wir brauchen ist eine
Verantwortungsgemeinschaft eine Rückkehr
zum Geist des kommunikäs von 2014 liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen Sie uns
heute einen Neustart nach den
Diskussionen der letzten Monate Wagen
lassen sie uns zeigen dass wir eins
verstanden haben die Qualität der
frühkindlichen Bildung ist Ausdruck
unser Verantwortung für die Zukunft
unserer Gesellschaft danke schön
Erik von malottki war das ist besteht
Handlungsbedarf denn das sogenannte gute
Kita-Gesetz läuft zum Jahresende aus für
den kommenden beiden Jahre muss sich der
Bund mit den Ländern einigen und er
braucht eine Zustimmung im Bundesrat ein
zustimmungspflichtiges Gesetz deswegen
hier noch mal der Appell an die
Verantwortungsgemeinschaft sicher auch
von Katja Adler von der FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
kita-qualität bedeutet Zukunft und das
sollte sich nicht so wie bisher
überwiegend auf kostenfreie Kitaplätze
beschränken da dies dann auch wenig mit
Qualität oder qualitativ
anspruchsvoller Betreuung gemein hat war
eine Reform und Weiterentwicklung das
Gute Kita-Gesetz unumgänglich
kita-qualität bedeutet daher ausreichend
gutes und gut ausgebildetes Fachpersonal
in den Einrichtungen
kitaqualität bedeutet eine starke
Leitung die sich auf ihre pädagogischen
Kernaufgaben konzentrieren kann befreit
von den vielen administrativen
Notwendigkeiten
kita-qualität bedeutet sich in der
Pädagogik an der kindlichen Entwicklung
zu orientieren oder eine gesunde
abwechslungsreiche frisch gekochte
Ernährung ausreichend Bewegung und den
Schutz des Kindes sicherzustellen Kita
kita-qualität bedeutet aber auch eine
pädagogisch starke Kindertagespflege
ausgeschlossen ist nun endlich und das
das mehr als die Hälfte der Mittel wie
zum Beispiel in Bayern liebe Frau Bär
Geschehen allein für den dort gesetzten
Schwerpunkt weniger Gebühren ausgegeben
werden die
corona-pandemie zieht massive
Auswirkungen nach sich dies in den
Handlungsfeldern zu berücksichtigen ist
nur konsequent
den gestiegenen förderbedarfen in den
verschiedenen Bildungsbereichen den
Problemen in der sprachlichen
motorischen und so zur emotionalen
Entwicklung oder der Häufung psychischer
Auffälligkeiten wird im
kitaqualitätsgesetz Rechnung getragen
mit jeweils zwei Milliarden Euro für die
nächsten zwei Jahre machen wir einen
wichtigen und richtigen Schritt hin zu
mehr Qualität in der
Kindertagesbetreuung
weitere Schritte wie zum Beispiel die
bundesweite Standard zu verankern müssen
und werden nun folgen und das liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sind wir
unseren Kindern schuldig herzlichen Dank
soweit der Debatten Beitrag von Katja
Adler FDP-Fraktion gleich als letzte
Rednerin in diesem debattenpunkt Kita
qualitätsgesetz Jasmina Hostert und als
letzten Tagesordnungspunkt heute an
diesem Freitagnachmittag erwarten wir
dann die Aktuelle Stunde auf Antrag der
afd-fraktion über die Radikalisierung
der klimaproteste durch diesen Punkt
aber auch die vorherige Abstimmung
begleitet sie dann mein Kollege Hans
Werner Fittkau zu werfen das Qualität
nicht der das entscheidende Element hier
in diesem Gesetzes ist echt schäbig
Liebe Union
und vielleicht sie haben sich
anscheinend diese sieben Handlungsfelder
nicht angeschaut in die wir investieren
wollen ich kann sie ihm sehr gerne hier
Vorlesen
bedarfgerechtes Angebot
fachkraft-kindschlüssel Gewinnung und
Sicherung von qualifizierten Fachkräften
starke Leitung sprachliche Bildung
Maßnahmen zur kindlichen Entwicklung
Gesundheit Ernährung und Bewegung
Stärkung der kindes-
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich finde
das kita-qualitätsgesetz kann sich
wirklich sehen lassen wir nehmen in den
nächsten zwei Jahren circa vier
Milliarden Euro in die Hand weil uns
wichtig ist dass jedes Kind
frühkindliche Bildung erfährt weil uns
unsere Erzieherinnen und Erzieher
wichtig sind und weil wir wollen dass
sich Eltern auf eine gute
Kinderbetreuung verlassen können und
dabei überlassen wir nichts dem Zufall
wir sorgen dafür dass überall ob bei mir
in Böblingen oder hier in Berlin die
gleichen
Qualitätsstandards und Rahmenbedingungen
gelten damit alle Kinder die gleichen
Startchancen erhalten bekommen
und eben wurde gesagt dass überall in
allen Kitas die Erzieherinnen und auch
die Kinder gestresst sind also ich kann
genau das Gegenteil gerade berichten ich
mache gerade oder ich habe vor zwei
Wochen angefangen die Eingewöhnungsphase
mit meinem Sohn in der Kita zu machen
und dort ist eine sehr gute Stimmung
auch wenn ich natürlich sehe dass der
Arbeitsaufwand den die Erzieherinnen und
Erzieher leisten enorm ist aber dafür
habe ich den allergrößten Respekt was
unsere Erzieherinnen und Erzieher
leisten
sie bespaßen die Kinder sie trösten die
Kinder sie organisieren alles nebenbei
und haben dabei immer auch noch die
Bedürfnisse von jedem einzelnen Kind im
Blick das ist wirklich ein Kraftakt und
die Erzieherinnen und Erzieher verdienen
unsere größte Anerkennung und auch
unsere größte Unterstützung die sie
jetzt auch durch das
kita-qualitätsgesetz bekommen
und zum Schluss möchte ich noch eins
erwähnen weil wir so oft und so viel
auch über den Fach- und
Arbeitskräftemangel reden für die Eltern
ist eine
Kinderbetreuung essentiell vor allem für
Frauen da sie nach wie vor entweder zu
Hause oder in Minijobs oder in Teilzeit
stecken wir brauchen die Frauen dringend
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt und auch dafür
wollen wir mit diesem qualitätsgesetz
sorgen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen heute ist
ein guter Tag wir setzen ein zentrales
Vorhaben aus dem Koalitionsvertrag um
und mit dem kita-qualitätsgesetz stärken
wir die frühkindlichen Bildung ich freue
mich vielen Dank
das war nochmal zum Schluss dieser
Debatte Jasmina Hoster von der
SPD-Fraktion mitgeht im
Familienausschuss und jetzt kommt es zur
Abstimmung über diesen Gesetzentwurf
Kita
qualitätsgesetz liebe Zuschauer sie
sehen das Plenum hat sich schon wieder
ganz ordentlich gefüllt denn gleich gibt
es noch eine richtiges Aufreger Thema
aktuelle Stunde zu den Protestaktionen
der sogenannten letzten Generation darum
geht's gleich jetzt aber die Abstimmung
wir hören da mal rein
in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen ich
bitte diejenigen die dem Gesetzentwurf
in der ausschussfassung zustimmen wollen
um das Handzeichen das ist die SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP wer stimmt
dagegen
Entschuldigung haben sie dazu bestimmt
also dann war das SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen FDP und AFD haben zugestimmt
wer hat dagegen gestimmt das habe ich
jetzt nicht erwartet sorry die cdu/csu
stimmt dagegen wer enthält sich die
Linke
dann ist der Gesetzentwurf in zweiter
Beratung angenommen vielen Dank für den
Hinweis noch mal dritte Beratung und
Schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
das ist die SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
FDP und die AFD wer stimmt dagegen
das ist die cdu/csu und wer enthält sich
das ist DIE LINKE damit ist der
Gesetzentwurf endgültig angenommen und
das gibt es auch nicht alle Tage im
Deutschen Bundestag dass die AFD mit den
Fraktionen der Ampel stimmt aber in
diesem Fall ist es so Kita
qualitätsgesetz somit also angenommen
Drucksache 4735 wer stimmt für den
Entschließungsantrag das ist die cdu/csu
wer stimmt dagegen
das ist DIE LINKE Bündnis 90 die Grünen
SPD und FDP wer enthält sich die AFD der
Entschließungsantrag ist abgelehnt
Abstimmung über den Entschließungsantrag
der Fraktion Die Linke auf Drucksache 47
34 wer stimmt für diesen
Entschließungsantrag das ist die linke
und die AFD wer stimmt dagegen
das ist die SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
FDP und cdu/csu wer enthält sich niemand
dann ist der Entschließungsantrag
abgelehnt